hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast cost-benefit analysis of
expanding bone marrow drive using
thermal stem cells using automated cell
expansion methods versus manual methods
in Judy O'Rourke of leopards and I'll be
your moderator for today's event today's
webcast is presented by Lawrence comm
the leading social media site for
science professionals and sponsored by -
Remo BCT - room obesity is a global
leader in blood component therapeutic a
phoresis and cellular technology it is
the only company with the unique
combination of a phoresis collections
manual and automated whole blood
processing and pathogen reduction
technologies to rule LD CTD believes in
the potential of blood to do even more
for patients than it does today
disbelief inspires the company's
innovation and strengthens its
collaboration with customers to learn
more about Jerome o BCT please visit
www.gfi.com/webmonitor questions or
leave a comment answer is welcome - and
you can do this by hitting the green Q&A
button at the lower left of the
presentation window and typing in your
comments and questions we'll try to get
to as many as we can and we'll follow up
if you don't have time today want a
better look you can enlarge the slide
window by clicking on the screen icon in
the lower right hand corner of the slide
window if you can't hear or see this
presentation properly let us know by
clicking on the support button on the
top right or use the Q&A button we'll
make sure we try to resolve any issues
now let's get right to today's presenter
we are proud to welcome Tina Russell and
taa be athena russell news the lead
medical laboratory scientist of the
human cellular therapy laboratory and
assistant professor of laboratory
medicine and pathology at the Mayo
Clinic in Jacksonville Florida she has
held multiple positions at the Mayo
Clinic concentrating her work on news in
Como and he met
planet stem-cell research and other
cellular and cell derived therapies
athena also holds elected positions with
the International Society for cellular
therapy and the American Association of
bio analysts I will now turn the
presentation over to Athena Russell
I'm Athena wrestling from the human
cellular therapy laboratory at Mayo
Clinic down in Jacksonville Florida I
appreciate you all being here for this
webinar today and it's a pleasure to be
able to talk to you about an analysis
that we did in our laboratory over the
course of about a year or so as we were
considering transitioning away from
using manual methods to expand bone
marrow Mozingo mole stem cells towards a
more automated bioreactor type system
and we really just wanted to know
whether or not it was going to be
feasible for us to do that given the
resources that we had to give you a
little bit of background about our
laboratory so you have some perspective
our lab was established about 25 years
ago but specifically to support the bone
marrow transplant program and to perform
traditional cellular therapy and Hamada
products themselves activities it wasn't
until about four or five years ago that
we started to develop protocols for
investigational cellular therapies with
funding for the center from the Center
for regenerative medicine at Mayo Clinic
so we've been developing all of our GMP
production protocols for MS ES and for
some other newer novel therapies that
we're getting into as well now but we
only have about 1,200 square feet of
space to share with the bone marrow
transplant team and our regenerative
medicine team and we had some recent
renovations where we could take some of
the laboratory and turn it into clean
room space for GMP manufacturing however
we're also not only limited in space but
we're also limited in staff we only have
about three technologists working on all
of this work two of them on the bench
and one of them that handles all of the
quality and this is just a bird's-eye
view of what this 1,200 square feet
looks like we have one cell processing
area dedicated to bone marrow transplant
product processing all of our storage
space is located here dry storage and
cold storage so all of the liquid
nitrogen storage for
see - ATM - 20 storage it's all located
and this within this footprint and then
down towards the bottom is all the newly
renovated space where there are two labs
that are certified as clean rooms
however because we are so limited we can
only use one of them for true
manufacturing and the other one we still
are needing to perform all of our
research and development work and these
are just some images from the lab so you
can see kind of what I'm talking about
the picture on the left is of the larger
cleanroom space that we are needing for
research and development activities so
it's a little bit of a larger space and
of course we have to flow hoods and to
standard size co2 incubators and this is
the smaller of the two rooms the
cleanroom space where we actually
perform our manufacturing processes this
is an older picture but at this time we
now have a small laminar flow hood in
the back and we have to quantum Sol
expansion systems over on the right-hand
side and then on the left here is our
sanur cell processing workstation in
which we still have and it's really
where we began when we were developing
all of our manual cell expansion
protocols so to give you an idea of what
our short-term goals are with respect to
manufacturing again we're a small
facility we're an academic manufacturing
facility and so we really only have the
ability to support phase one and phase
two clinical trials but what we really
want to do is to be able to support
those clinical trials that are initiated
by investigators and clinician
investigators here at the Mayo Clinic
campus in Florida so that we can promote
regional medicine and cell therapy on
our campus so we want to be able to
support the main factoring needs of
those here who are interested in running
and developing iron.i MDS for
regenerative medicine and cell therapy
but again as I've mentioned a few times
now we have some pretty obvious
limitations and challenges before us we
have a very limited amount of space that
we have to work with and a very limited
staff that we have to perform all of the
development activities and manufacturing
activities so I want to give you an idea
of what our manual manufacturing
protocols were looking like we use the
cell processing workstation as you saw
in the images earlier if you're not
familiar the still processing
workstation is a standalone isolator
type of system it is a class 100
environment on the inside once it's been
decontaminated it has its own
incorporated hydrogen peroxide
decontamination system it also has
everything else that you need to do cell
culture like a centrifuge a microscope
and an incubator the incubators are
modular so you can add additional
incubators if you need to but we don't
have the space for that so we just have
one modular incubator that's only 1.4
cubic feet on the inside contrast that
with a standard cell culture incubator
that has about 6 cubic feet of space on
the inside so we are working with a much
less space than what we're used to
having to handle all of our incubation
means we use multi layer flasks and with
all the options out there on the market
we were able to narrow it down to two
different types that we could use with
this modular incubator that those were
the millah for high flash which have
about a thousand square centimeters of
growth area and the corning hyper class
which RT 1720s
this is what they look like and for all
of our manufacturing methods we use
alpha mem and 5% platelet lysate we've
gotten away from SPS some time ago and
this is how we would do it we would
start by expanding MSC's up to passage 1
to create a master cell bank of vials of
MSC's
to do that we were able to scale up to a
maximum of 10 t1 thousands last that's
the maximum number of flats that we can
fit inside the modular incubator in
those 10 C 1000 last we could produce
enough cells about 200 million MSC s
to freeze down about 100 vials of 2
million MSC s per vial for our master
solving after that when we're ready to
create a batch of product we could pull
vials from the master cell bank and
further expand them up to passage 3 to
create batches of stem cell products
that are intended to be used for therapy
to do that we could scale up to a
maximum of 10 T 1720 flasks and at the
end of all this we could approximately
create about 4 doses of product and each
each dose would have a hundred million
MF fees in the bag from start to finish
which is from the raw bone marrow
aspirate all the way to creating the
very first batch of stem cell product
doses that manufacturing campaign would
take anywhere from six to eight weeks to
complete so there are some pretty
obvious limitations to doing it this way
first of all you can only fit a maximum
of ten of either type of multi-layer
flasks inside the incubator so you're
really limited in how many cells you can
produce the whole process from start to
finish is extremely tedious very
time-consuming and labor-intensive you
really absolutely need at least two
technologists to perform these tasks
efficiently I have done it with one
before during the development phase and
it just is not feasible you consume a
huge number or huge volume of culture
medium doing it this way each of the
Corning hyper flasks requires five
hundred and sixty-five milliliters of
culture medium to fill up the flask
completely which you have to do with
those flasks and so you can imagine
towards the end when you have ten hyper
flasks and every time you do a medium
change you need six liters approximately
six liters of media so you can see how
the cost and medium and play of lysate
can really add up doing it
swing and it's a relatively long period
of time from start to finish and at the
end you really do not get that many
doses of products so you're putting in a
lot and you're not really getting a lot
out of it so it didn't take long for us
to realize that we needed to make some
changes and do some things differently
so we started thinking about bioreactors
we looked at a few different systems
there were three different systems that
we considered that were small footprint
single-use platforms one of them of
course was the through mobi CT quantum
cell expansion system one of the
platforms required the use of micro
carriers and the other two platforms the
cells grew out in a more traditional
two-dimensional model layer type of
manner however one of those platforms we
had to exclude kind of early on for
space considerations because although it
was indeed a small footprint type of
platform it still required a little bit
more instrumentation to go along with
the whole thing than we had space for so
in the end we narrowed it down to two
systems the micro carrier system in the
quantum and we brought them both
in-house and tested them for expanding
bone marrow MFCs so we thoroughly
evaluated these two systems and
eventually we decided that we had to
rule out the micro carrier system a big
part of this was the amount of
involvement in the time that we were
going to need to translate our current
2d system to a 3d system because really
if you've never worked in micro carriers
before they're just so different from
growing cells in flasks and there's a
lot of steps that need to be worked out
and developed along the way and we did a
lot of this during the evaluation phase
we did micro carrier screening assays
where we looked at a whole bunch of
different micro carriers and tried to
figure out which ones were going to work
best for our needs and for our cell type
there was also considerations regarding
the way that you have to prepare the
micro carrier some of them
our pre-sterilized some of them need to
be autoclaved some of them many of them
need to be pre hydrated and all of these
things you have to think about and in
fact we don't have easy access to an
autoclave we have to walk across the
street to get to one and so obviously
this wasn't really an ideal situation
for us regarding monitoring of the
culture you have to think about that not
knowing when the cells are going to be
confluent on the carriers and also you
need to keep a certain cell to micro
carrier ratio so after a certain amount
of time yes add more micro carriers and
you have to figure out how to how to
know when to do that so again just more
steps that need more development and
then there's the question of how to
harvest the cells from the micro
carriers and once you do how will you
separate the micro carriers from the
cells you may need additional equipment
like a fluidized bed centrifuge a lot of
the techniques micro carrier separation
techniques that were on the market at
the time when we did this evaluation
were designed for very large scale
applications and not really for
processing volumes in the 5 liter range
which is where we were and then after
all this how can you do your purity
testing how can you be sure that you
have no micro care contamination in the
final product so again these are all
things that we could have worked out
over time but each one of these steps
needed to be developed and tested and it
would have taken a very considerable
amount of time for the two technologists
that we had doing this work so again we
eventually had to rule this this
platform out so we narrowed our options
down to the platform but we still really
weren't sure if this was going to be
right for us there were some obvious
benefits to using the quantum like the
small footprint with the eliminative
space that we have and also the relative
ease of translating our current
protocols to using the bioreactor there
was a reduction in the amount of time it
took for us to expand the cells and also
we were able to after doing a number of
pilot runs with Guillermo's help get to
where we could produce greater cell
yields in the bioreactor versus using
flasks and we're also able to keep the
cells at a lower passage for banking and
for
production of MSC products but probably
the most valuable advantage for our
particular situation was the addition of
automation because it saved us so much
time with performing manual tasks and
there's also the possibility of
scalability with a quantum we have a
5,000 square-foot GMP facility that is
being planned out right now hopefully
for this year or next year and so
hopefully when we get this new facility
and we have a little bit more space we
can add more Quantum's
and once we're familiar with the
protocol we can just do the same
protocol with more Quantum's and able
and we'll be able to get more cell
yields so I'm trying to determine
whether or not this platform was going
to be right for us we had to ask the
question whether or not this automated
platform was going to measure up in
every sense to the current manual
protocol that we were using we looked at
a number of different parameters and we
did the analysis and we were able to put
out this poster that we presented the
world stem cell somewhat a couple years
ago if any was interested in looking at
this poster please feel free to email me
but I'm going to go over what we found
in the subsequent slides and again to
highlight work what our overarching
goals were first and foremost we needed
the ability to expand large quantities
of MSDS so that we could treat patients
in cell therapy and render medicine
clinical trials and manufacture those
cells in compliance with GMP standards
and so with this analysis we wanted to
be able to compare the automated versus
manual method with regard to cell yields
cost time and effort from the
technologist and just overall ease of
performing the protocols so what we did
was we started with 20 about 25 to 30
milliliters of fresh bone-marrow
aspirate and we performed the automated
method and the manual method basically
side by side we isolated and expanded
Romero MSC s using alpha mem and 5%
human play a little I say we created
master cell banks using the automated
method and the manual method and
products using both methods as well and
then we just quantified the difference
as we look
again cell yields we looked at the cost
of consumables and reagents needed to
perform these two different methods how
long it took to grow the cells how much
effort it required from the
technologists and how many technologists
we needed to do all the work first
looking at the automated method you're
able to dilute the bone marrow and add
it directly to the quantum system you
don't have to pre isolate the mono
nuclear cells as you normally do you do
have to pre coat the bioreactor with
fiber neck and overnight or else the
cells will not adhere in order to
monitor the culture you look at glucose
consumption lactate generation and you
can also see control flasks at the same
seating densities just to give you a
visual of how confluent the cells are to
help aid in your decision as to when the
cells are ready to be harvested you can
freeze down cells into vials as early as
p0 but you get a lot more cells at p1
and so we typically expand up to p1 to
create our master cell bank but you will
have additional vials at p0 that you can
further expand to p1 to create more
cells to Bank and then of course
eventually up to create more products
the product product bags can be
generated as early as passage 2 so you
pull vials from passage 1 from the
master cell Bank and then just expand
them up one more passage to create doses
and the total area surface area for
growth inside one bioreactor is 21,000
square centimeters for the manual method
we first isolated the mononuclear cells
from the bone marrow using cycle and
then feed them directly to t1000 flasks
that were not coated had actually fifty
to a hundred thousand cells per
centimeter squared we provide a fresh
media every three to four days
passage of the cells when they were
about eighty-five to ninety percent
confluent and we froze down master cell
bank files at passage 1 we then pulled
vials from the master cell bank to
expand products but we couldn't do that
we couldn't actually freeze products
down until passage 3 because you don't
have that many cells in your vial for
passage 1 so you have to first expand
them to passage 2 and then you
really scale up by passage three so a
very important thing to understand about
how we did this analysis because we
didn't do this based on using the cell
processing workstation knowing that most
people don't have one most people are
going to be doing this these
manufacturing processes in a cleanroom
with standard cell culpable standard
cell culture incubators so we wanted to
sort of normalize this so that knowing
that everybody has a different kind of
situation and and not everybody has the
same number of incubators in their
laboratories we wanted to just kind of
normalize the whole analysis down to the
number of cells you could produce using
one standard size six cubic foot cell
culture incubator and so in one standard
six cubic foot cell culture incubator we
were able to fit a maximum of 48 Corning
hyper flasks p1 1720 into one of those
incubators for a maximum capacity is
about 82,000 square centimeters for cell
growth and this is what we came up with
I know this is a busy slide and I will
summarize it later but so you can see
how we did it we looked first at all of
the reagents and consumables that we
would need to perform each process using
each method and for all the passages
that we need to perform using each
method these are the cost for the
quantum and the required passages
associated with using the quantum and
also the cost for expanding manually and
these are all the parameters that we
looked at we looked at how much did it
cost to run each passage that we would
need to run exactly how much time it
would take to actually expand each
passage how much hands-on time it would
take from the technologists actually
performing tasks and how many
technologists you would need to perform
the tasks and then of course we looked
at approximations of how many cells you
should be able to expect from each of
these passages doing it one way or the
other and how many
biles you can freeze down to create a
bank and how many doses you can expect
to manufacture and so finally we really
wanted to make sense of all of this data
and we wanted to kind of put it into
terms that would make sense to other
laboratories that were in the same
situation as a smaller laboratories that
want to support a clinical trial at
their institution that they have limited
resources and so what we did was we
imagined a hypothetical clinical trial
that happening at our institution where
each subject is supposed to receive one
dose of 100 million MSC s and we wanted
to ask whether or not it would be
possible for us to manufacture the doses
needed for this clinical trial and how
much would it cost us to do it so
looking at cost what we found was that
to manufacture these hundred doses using
the quantum they would cost about a
hundred thousand dollars or a thousand
dollars for those or $10 per million MSP
however doing it the manual way using
multi layer flasks in a single cell
culture incubator it would cost about
two hundred thousand dollars to create
the same number of doses and so the cost
were about double and the majority of
that cost came really from the cell
culture media and cell culture
supplement because doing the manual
method using multi-layer Flass that
require such large volumes of media it
just adds up the cost greatly and so the
majority of that increased cost really
came from the huge amounts of media that
you needed to do this procedure manually
versus using the automated quantum
system looking at this in terms of time
if you have just a single quantum it
takes it was to take about 13 passage to
runs to create the hundred doses that
you need to run this trial if you
perform all of those runs
back-to-back non-stop it would take
approximately 20 weeks or five months to
perform all of the manufacturing
activities needed
to generate those doses although it is
nice to have two technologists to
perform these tasks if it came down to
it you really only need one to do
everything because the tasks are so
automated and that one technologist only
needs to spend about 34 total hours of
hands-on work to do everything required
in order to generate all of these doses
in contrast using the manual method you
would need to perform five runs and
within that and each run is defined as
pulling a vial from the master cell bank
and expanding out the passage to and
then a passage 3 to get your your batch
if you do all those batch runs
back-to-back it takes just a little
longer about 24 weeks or six months the
original primary culture can be done
with one technologist but all of the
works that subsequent to that you really
need at least two technologists to
perform these tasks efficiently and with
those two technologists each one of them
would need to expend almost 200 hours of
hands-on time doing all of the manual
tasks required to harvest all of those
48 flasks that you could fit into one
cell culture incubator if you have
additional incubator space you can have
more growth area and therefore more cell
yields but then again you'll you're
going to expend more medium and you're
going to need even more label labor to
handle the increase in flasks and
processing time so you really need more
people to handle that many flasks is the
takeaway points if you want to not
compromise the quality of your product
and the viability of the cells so in
summary we found that using the quantum
automated system instead of using the
manual multi layer flask based protocols
resulted in almost a 50% reduction in
the cost of reagents and consumables
needed to produce
100 doses of MSDS to run this
hypothetical clinical trial and using
the automated method resulted and about
a 17% decrease in the amount of actual
time needed to grow out this many cells
and using the automated method resulted
in an 82% reduction in the number of
hours needed to be expended by the
technologist in order to do all this
work and only require the effort of one
technologist versus two or more
technologists to do all the manual tasks
efficiently and we've concluded that we
are able to produce large quantities of
bone marrow Mozingo stem cells for
clinical use using the automated quantum
system and that it requires
significantly less cost time and effort
on our part to do this over the manual
method using certain multi-layer flasks
and that indeed is the method the
platform that we have gone with for all
of our future manufacturing needs
you
excellent presentation Athena thanks for
bringing that information to us we now
welcome Brent rice PhD from the sole
processing team at Tru mobi CT was a
collaborator with Athena and now joins
us to answer your questions before we
get started with the Q&A sessions here's
a quick reminder about how to reach us
today questions can be sent they have a
green Q&A button at the lower left of
the presentation window we'll get to as
many as we can our first question is did
you do a comparability study between
sell products grown in a flask and cells
grown in the bioreactor yes indeed
Athena did perform a comparability study
according to their critical quality
attributes so they're indications of
identity purity potency and safety and
they found that there was no significant
difference between the two populations
I should also generally say that this is
something that is pursued by many and
probably most of our customers anybody
with a historical process of course has
their defined critical quality
attributes and then they test to ensure
that the cells produced by the quantum
system maintain these critical quality
quality attributes does your cost
include disposable cost of the quantum
yes the analysis that Athena provided
there are many line items one of which
is the the quantum disposables or
several of which are the quantum
disposables just as she also lists the
hyper flasks for the manual process and
one any attendee asks could I get a copy
of the presentation and the poster
mentioned the the slides is currently
aren't available for distribution
however to my understanding this
presentation itself should be available
for the next six months as of today on
the labyrinth lab routes website okay we
have time for one last question if we
didn't get your
we'll follow up with you via email the
last question is have cells from the
quantum being used in patients since it
require a GMT facility so yes you know
at this point the quantum system has
been used to produce many cells that
have been used in a variety of
treatments certainly early on more of
this use was in the context of
compassionate use or Hospital exemption
so for example treatment of GVHD as a
3rd line treatment or you know again a
last case resort for that that horrible
disease however thankfully you know over
the years more and more people have
submitted IMD's and more and more of
these IDs in the US are coming to
fruition in clinical studies so a couple
of examples would be for inflammatory
bowel disease and in glioma treatment
and then in the EU as well we're seeing
a similar pattern the most chronic are
the most significant clinical trial
actually in the world is in the EU where
they've treated well over 50 patients
for heart failure with adipose derived
MSC's and with regard to the question of
facility of course the most important
thing to acknowledge there is that that
the delineation of what type of facility
is necessary is a function purely of the
local regulatory authorities that being
said of course having a functionally
closed an automated system like the
quantum system allows you some more
flexibility and ability to make some
very good arguments for lowering the
classification of the that clean room
facility so it is not uncommon it is
quite common and even Envy the largest
clinical trial example that I that I
just mentioned in that case while a
flash-based process would have to be
pursued in a Class B facility in the EU
they have pursued the the use of the
quantum system in a class C facility
which has obvious benefits regarding
ease of use and and of course the the
costs of the facility itself
so yes so more and more prominent
clinical production and a tendency
towards using lower grade clean rooms as
well good I would like to once again
thank Tina Russell and grant rice for
this presentation would also like to
thank our sponsor two-room obesity for
making it possible to bring this
presentation to you today's webcast will
be available for on-demand viewing
through January 12 2018 you'll receive
an email from us alerting you is
available on demand and posted on lavage
comm you are welcome to Ford this
announcement to any colleagues who
weren't able to join in today thanks for
logging on and participating in today's
broadcast we'll see you next time